you know if we didn't have a
moon we wouldn't have
werewolves that's kind of interesting no
werewolves what else wouldn't we have we
wouldn't have romantic evenings By
Moonlight I don't know what Beethoven
would have called his Moonlight
Sonata these are
questions it's just fun to think about
how different we would be culturally
emotionally spiritually without it other
than the Western calendar which is based
on Earth Seasons most of the other
well-known calendars of the world are
moon-based okay the Chinese calendar the
Jewish calendar the Muslim calendar
they're moon-based so they have to find
something else to base the calendar on
plus would we have a space
program without the moon as a
destination to draw
us just thoughts to contemplate the next
time you gaze up at our moon